hoy ha vuelto a elevarse la atención en
el puerto de odessa estábamos frente a
ese puerto que es el más importante de
ucrania las autoridades no nos dejan
firmar pero hoy se ha anunciado que esas
diez embarcaciones rusas que por días
estuvieron rodeando las aguas de la
ciudad frente a la costa han regresado
el mal tiempo se ha terminado y ya se
espera de nuevo un ataque en los
próximos días esta ciudad está
totalmente
militarizada especialmente en el centro
en los últimos días ha crecido la
atención y especialmente el número de
hombres que la están protegiendo hay
barreras protegiendo los monumentos como
vemos a las espaldas que es uno de los
monumentos más importantes de la ciudad
yo hablando con el alcalde esta mañana
en una entrevista que dio para france24
aseguraba que la única manera de
proteger ese gran casco histórico de
odessa era haciendo una exclusión aérea
sobre la ciudad lo que hasta ahora
parece
imposible así que la ciudad vuelve a
esperar un ataque aunque sigue tratando
al menos los que viven aquí de tener una
vida normal